[MUSIC] It's been
three years, you [ __ ] bastard, have
you
finally gone to bed?
]
I'll do it
[music]
Instead of the old lady, wait for that store for a while
Then you'll live with us You look so
cute, you're a ally
of justice, and the bad guys are punished with an
iron fist I wonder if the
rice has become cute  I
came here because I was able to do it, so let's eat together I'm
unreliable as both a boss and a man It's no joke to end up losing The
cafe terrace familia's counterattack starts here  I can't get
up early because I specialize in getting dirty
Think of you guys as a comfortable family All the customers who come to this store are
familia [
music] Are
these the goddesses who save this store or the
gods of poverty who destroy the store?
Welcome to [music] where I got involved with some really messy guys